bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro cordero
Este 10 de Abril se cumple el 25
aniversario del acuerdo de viernes Santo
un pacto que selló las bases para poner
fin al conflicto norierlandés luego de
tres décadas de violencia entre los
republicanos católicos y los unionistas
protestantes quienes mantuvieron una
lucha interreligiosa que tuvo un
carácter político nacionalista e
interétnico y se cobró la vida de más de
3.500 personas
para entender De dónde viene el
conflicto nor Irlandés hay que
remontarse a la historia la isla de
Irlanda de mayoría católica perteneció a
Reino Unido hasta 1922 cuando una gran
parte del territorio logró su
independencia tras una guerra contra
Londres sin embargo el ulster una región
en el norte de la isla con mayoría
protestante y con población británica
tras siglos de colonización se mantuvo
dentro del Reino Unido en Irlanda del
Norte esa mayoría protestante dominó
durante décadas todas las instituciones
del territorio y marginó y reprimió a La
minoría Católica y étnicamente irlandesa
intentando eliminar cualquier signo de
su identidad cultural esto provocó que
En 1968 miles de católicos irlandeses
salieran a las calles a protestar por
sus derechos algo que fue contestado por
las autoridades con violencia durante
años el republicanismo irlandés
unirse al resto de Irlanda Pero a este
objetivo se oponían los llamados
unionistas protestantes que eran
Defensores de permanecer bajo el
paraguas de Reino Unido y la monarquía
británica en este contexto convulso es
en el que nace el ir a provisional una
decisión del ejército republicano
Irlandés que decidió abrazar la vía
Armada para expulsar al Reino Unido de
La Isla sin embargo el ira no sería el
único responsable del aumento de la
violencia ya que los unionistas crearon
varios grupos paramilitares como el uda
o la fuerza voluntaria lealista que ante
lo que consideraban que era pasividad de
Londres atentaban asesinaban y
perseguían a católicos y republicanos un
caos generalizado que desembocó que en
1972 Reino Unido decidiera eliminar la
autonomía de Irlanda del Norte
Precisamente en el año más violento que
terminó con 480 víctimas mortales
algunas de ellas fallecieron en
conocidas matanzas como la del Domingo
sangriento cuando el ejército británico
asesinó a 14 manifestantes o la del
viernes sangriento en la que el ira
detonó 22 bombas simultáneamente en
Irlanda del Norte y mató a nueve
personas como respuesta y aunque la
violencia se redujo notablemente en los
años siguientes llegando a ver menos de
100 muertos anuales los atentados se
multiplicaron en el resto de Reino Unido
llegando a tentar incluso contra la
entonces primera ministra margaret
thatcher tras poner una bomba en su
hotel
[Música]
hoy es hablar de estas atrocidades de
estas bombas pero no esperas que te
ocurran a ti
pero la vida debe seguir como siempre
la reducción de la violencia se dio de
forma paralela a un proceso de desgaste
en las filas de vida provisional y de
los grupos paramilitares unionistas
quienes empezaron a acusar numerosas
bajas este contexto propició a que desde
inicios de los 90 se comenzara a hablar
de una posible paz un objetivo en el que
ganó protagonismo un partido considerado
como la rama política de Lira
provisional el sinfein
25 años de violencia no han producido
ningún avance para nadie y sí mucha
miseria para todos lo que hay en este
documento es una indicación lo más clara
posible de que siempre que el ira esté
dispuesto a renunciar definitivamente a
la violencia Entonces el sinfen podrá
unirse a las conversaciones
exploratorias tras estas palabras Elida
declaró un alto el fuego en 1994 al que
siguió un cese de las hostilidades en
conjunto con los grupos paramilitares
unionistas con este clima de tensa calma
comenzaron las negociaciones entre los
republicanos norierlandeses los grupos
unionistas el Reino Unido y la República
de Irlanda y salvo un periodo de vuelta
a la violencia en 1996 el proceso
culminó con unos históricos acuerdos el
10 de Abril de 1998 durante el viernes
santo de ese año
me complace anunciar que los dos
gobiernos y los partidos políticos de
Irlanda del Norte han llegado a un
acuerdo
propone cambios en la Constitución
irlandesa y en la ley constitucional
británica para consagrar el principio de
que es el pueblo de Irlanda del Norte El
que decidirá democráticamente su propio
futuro
en el texto se garantizaban algunas de
las demandas históricas del
republicanismo como la opción a la doble
nacionalidad el libre paso fronterizo la
formación de un autogobierno con poder
repartido entre los dos bandos y la
reforma de la policía
el acuerdo fue refrendado por el
71,1% de los norierlandeses que
apostaron por lograr la paz e Irlanda
cesó en su reclamaciones territoriales y
Reino Unido sacó a su ejército de la
zona el tratado no trajo la paz
inmediata ya que a los pocos meses se
vivió el atentado de Omar que dejó 29
Muertos pero con el paso de los años los
sectores de Lira reacios a la paz fueron
perdiendo fuerza hasta que entregaron
sus armas en 2005 Irlanda del Norte
conoció desde entonces un periodo de paz
inédito en las últimas décadas que
solamente se vio amenazado tras el
brexit por la incertidumbre en torno a
la frontera Aunque finalmente Reino
Unido y la Unión Europea acordaron
mantener la libre circulación entre
Irlanda del Norte y la república
irlandesa para evitar a las tensiones de
los años atrás
con esto concluimos Gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]